there's a phrase if if you really like
someone you say I eat your liver well
that's what it translates to I eat your
liver to be honest with them
yeah please you didn't pronounce it
correctly but and then there's another
one I died on your body which means I'm
really into you you're great I die on
your body you say these phrases I mean
those are weird well when you say it's
so spooky yeah but you have to put love
it I died on your body you know I died
on your body where those come from you
know like for example if something bad
happens to you and we're very sorry we
say like hieronymus which means yeah may
I go blind instead of you may I go why
does anyone have to go blind you're
saying if someone cuts their finger oh
yeah yeah man so may I go blind instead
of you know no one has to go blind yeah
well we also have this one you may
relate to this boy it Mirman which is
may I die for your Heights it's when you
know somebody good job good job it's
translated as may I die or an M boy
going on yeah what's the flat head what
there's a weird head one right
yes there is and actually this is a
really good timing to teach America this
one
this comes may I iron your head ironing
head somebody's head like with my iron
may i iron your no I was just ironing
somebody said you look hard to kill
which is both yeah it's like you're both
usually use like stop ironing my head
like when you're out of line stop
ironing my head and
some people I know there's no connection
there's no way that that makes sense
oh you're that's boo may I take an iron
and iron your head out I need night man
I could I have to say this it changed my
life because since I went to Armenia
everywhere I go I never realized I knew
there were a lot of Armenians in the
United States everywhere I go people
come out of cars that come out of
bakeries they come out of and I learned
some phrases so I end up hugging a lot
of men and women oh yeah oh yeah there
are a lot of them here and we came to LA
a few days ago they gave us these which
are the keys to Glendale City he's to
the city oh wait a minute maybe you're
confused too I thought you were just
about to present me with the chaotic
LenDale and it turns out that you were
just showing me that you have one no
brick and rugs Greg and rugs but you
know we do stop guys are so out of here
stop ironing my heads exactly
yes
you